now if you don't like this video i hope
you'll stay subscribed and keep watching
everything i put out anyways because
maybe something will recontextualize and
make this
all worth it
hey everybody this one's gonna be a
little bit of an unstructured ramble
which at this point i usually try and
keep uh confined to the break room a
break room of geeks
subscribe if you're not already but we
are getting into the holidays and i'm
still
in the middle of editing the novel and
i've started on what is going to be one
of my bigger video projects so
yeah you got to cut me a little bit of
slack i want to talk about something
that
has kind of it's been on my mind in
general for a little while
and it tends to come up really with
anything that's a franchise
anything that is long running and is
going to theoretically have further
installments
into the future so this is your marvel
cinematic universes your dc movies
your star wars your your
harry potters at this point your doctor
who's star trek etc etc etc
there's this notion that i see in the
fandom
that it rides that line between
hopeful and harmful and it's this idea
of when something happens
that is divisive or
unsatisfying or feels incomplete
there is a number percentage of fans
who basically go well maybe it'll get
fixed later
or maybe it'll get explained later or
maybe something later will
justify this and i have a lot of
issues with that as a general mentality
and it's not a mentality that's even
confined to
films comic books or tv
because it's the same root mentality
that basically lets video game
developers release a
broken product and with the hope that
they will patch it later and
fix it i mean that and they've actually
built
business models around that that's what
the entire live service
concept with video games is but i'll try
not to go on that tangent
now let me be clear i'm not trying to
knock or
put down anyone who has a mentality of
well
i hope it gets better later that's an
optimism i can totally
get behind if a franchise that you love
has gone a direction that you don't like
i think it's a good thing to hope that
it becomes something you like again i've
gone through periods of that with a
number of things over the years whereas
like
okay at this point i'm not entirely sure
it's working for me but i hope it
will again that's not what i'm talking
about though
i'm talking about when something happens
be it
a plot point a character turn or just
a something that is brought out that
just leaves a crap ton of dangling
threads with no clear resolution
that people go well you know
later it'll be good later
here's my fundamental philosophical
problem with that
there's nothing wrong with having an eye
on the larger picture the grander
franchise an overarching story
what have you but if you're going to
release
an individual piece of media
be it a film a television show
an issue of a comic book or what have
you
if you're going to release that on its
own
as a piece of media that we may in some
cases have to actually pay for
then that should be satisfying in and of
itself
it should not do nothing other than
dangle a hook to say don't you want to
see where we go with this
now you can have your threads you can
have your things that you
use to lure people back for more
but what you give me now
still has to work in and of itself
now i'll try not to dwell on it too much
but i can't help
but think about the new star wars
trilogy
in relation to this and this was
honestly a big part of what got me
thinking about it although again as i
said i see this freaking
everywhere but i remember when
the force awakens came out and
was pretty good um i enjoyed it for the
most part
but there were a lot of things that were
very deliberately left unanswered
and not in the way that was done in
say a new hope which it took an awful
lot of cues from
because obviously at the end of new hope
vader's still around the empire hasn't
been defeated they just dealt with the
immediate problem there's a lot of work
still to do there are a lot of places to
go for the next installment but new hope
didn't flatly lay out a bunch of stuff
that you're left going
wait but what there were
vague illusions about luke's father
but the information you had in a new
hope was enough
to have you be satisfied for the
purposes of that story his father
was a jedi was too
tutored by obi-wan was killed by darth
vader now that would get
recontextualized later but for the
purposes of that film
that's enough the force awakens
on the other hand introduces
snoke who has no context
and ultimately would never really get
any it
does this massive blatant
laying of raised parentage
and regardless of how you feel about
where that ultimately
went and how it then got
backtracked again by rise of sky
whether or not you like what was done
either in
the last jedi or rise of skywalker with
rey's parentage you cannot deny that it
was something that was blatantly left
unsatisfying in that first film
it set up a question and did not even
give
a hint a vague thing of an answer it was
just
left there and at the time that it came
out
i gave that a pass i was like i'm sure
they'll pick up on that later and
obviously they did
but i still now consider that a fault of
the original film even separate from the
context
of what went on with that thing and how
it ping-ponged back and forth
with what the heck the purpose of that
was or as another comparative
let's look at the introduction of thanos
into the mcu versus the introduction
or not even really introduction the
hinting at
dark side in batman v superman
now thanos got his initial introduction
in a
mid-credit sequence in the avengers
and the reason that works is twofold
one the immediate situation has been
dealt with as far as what
the problems and the issues and the
story was for avengers we have a
complete story it's why it's in the mid
credits so that it's there for the
people who really care and people who
just wanted a fun ride
they've already left and they haven't
really lost anything for that
and we learn enough immediately about
him even though we don't know what his
goals are we don't know how he's going
about it
we don't really know who he is but
we know he is clearly the power
behind what loki was doing
so we know he's a threat and we know he
will come up
later but again immediate situation
completely dealt with
contrast that with batman v superman
which had batman's
nightmare sequence now in that sequence
amongst other things that don't really
pay off
there's there's there's this invasion of
parademons
and there's dark side symbol on the
ground
this doesn't work for a couple of
reasons the first is it's in the middle
of the film
which means that the story is actually
paused in order to lay this groundwork
that is not going to be paid off in any
meaningful way in
this film itself or even really
addressed again
not to mention the fact that it's a
symbol that means nothing unless you
already know the comics
you could watch the avengers and see the
introduction of thanos
not know who thanos is but still get an
idea of
what he is about and how he's going to
fit into this
that symbol the omega symbol for
darkseid
means nothing if you don't already
know the comics and again you're
sticking it in the middle of the film
you are highlighting it you are making
it part of your narrative
with no intention of paying it off here
and that's not even getting into the
little mini trailers that go on later on
in that same film
again setting up stuff that in no way
pays off in this film
i i'm not sure people always understand
why i tend to be a proponent
on say doctor who of the standalone
episodes over
series arcs now let's not say every
standalone episode is great or that none
of the series arc stories are good
there are exceptions in either direction
but my general preference
is for standalone story because i want
at the end of it to go yeah
that was nice not okay
i've got one piece of an ongoing story
i hope it's worth sticking with this to
find out how it fits together
because you see i'm old enough to
remember going to see the matrix sequels
in the theater
and going to see matrix reloaded and
being
very unsatisfied by its total non-ending
even knowing that later that same year
the conclusion was gonna come out
because they'd already shot it so it
wasn't like oh god i hope they get a
sequel no they had one
there was no question there but it still
wasn't all that satisfying
because it didn't allow me to feel like
i had a complete experience
i had half an experience and whether or
not that half was going to be worth it
was going to be completely dependent on
whether or not revolutions was any good
which
it's okay it's over hated but
you know realizing that these are part
of the same whole story ends up bringing
reloaded down a bit in my estimation
because
it doesn't stand on its own and the idea
of we'll fix it later well
maybe you will but maybe you'll also
drag it down
later in many ways studios
and directors and creators kind of
bank on the idea that
audiences will go well maybe this will
pay off later
maybe they'll they'll fix this thing
that they brought up and doesn't quite
make sense
yet later they bank on that
again to come back to star wars i didn't
mean to keep coming back to that
so much but jj abrams very deliberately
built that mystery in with the idea that
it would keep people coming back
but if you make a good star wars movie
we're gonna come back for more
you don't need to lay that stuff in and
the fact that
this whole oh but this will all pay off
later i mean like that was a huge part
of why the dark
universe universal's dark universe the
mummy completely collapsed in on itself
because
major swaths of it were nothing but
setups for stuff that was supposed to
happen later
but nobody was satisfied with the movie
that wasn't the only problem with that
movie there's a lot of problems with
that movie
but the fact that fans are so forgiving
about an individual piece of media in a
franchise that they like
it lays the groundwork for
people behind those franchises to take
advantage
and to string you along on the hope
that it'll be worth it in the end but i
don't want a story that it that
hinges 100 on whether or not the ending
works
because well
honestly that's what happened with game
of thrones
i didn't realize it at the time i don't
think most of us did but
that story because it is a continual
narrative
and it's not episodic really in any way
shape or form
the whole series was going to hinge
on sticking the landing because that's
what all of this stuff that we've been
enjoying was building towards
and when it didn't and when it
sucked because honestly that last season
sucks it makes it hard to go back and
even enjoy the good seasons again
because everything is building towards
that terrible last season
things don't stand on their own they
don't have satisfaction
as a standalone piece
because we kept getting strung along
every step of the way
going oh they're going to pay it off ooh
and again
i'm not saying that they shouldn't make
things like
game of thrones i mean if they stuck the
landing
maybe i'd be listing it as the exception
of how to do it right
but just be careful
about having your optimism turned into
making excuses for a piece of media that
doesn't actually satisfy in and of
itself
because the teasing the anticipation
the ooh this is going somewhere that's
fine and all
but it's foreplay try not to
let creators get away with doing nothing
but foreplay and never
actually getting the job done so to
speak
so that's gonna wrap up this one folks i
don't have a sponsor for this video
but i do want to shout out a kickstarter
which full disclosure i am friends with
the person running it and i am already a
backer on it
but i really want to see this thing
succeed
my friend hijo silver who is an artist
a burlesque performer just an all-around
really great person
on their tick tock earlier this year
they pitched this concept of a new take
on the joker a black female
anti-hero joker and go to the
kickstarter you can hear the pitch
and our main thing is just like if only
you
smiled it wouldn't be so threatening
that
you smiled they have paired with an
artist who could help make it happen
it's a brilliant concept that i want to
see through to the end and i think if
you go to the kickstarter link in the
description
and check out the pitch video i'm pretty
sure some of you are going to want to
see this too
so that's what i'm going to recommend
for you in lieu of any kind of sponsor
this week
i hope that if you celebrate
thanksgiving that you had a wonderful
one
and i hope that things are going okay
for you
going into december thank you for
watching
usual stuff like share subscribe i have
a patreon that is what pays my bills and
keeps this entire operation up and
running
and i appreciate absolutely any
amount of support that is given through
that but you also
don't have to end of the day you're the
council
i'm just running the meetings and until
next time this council
is adjourned
[Music]
hmm
[Applause]
[Music]
um
um
[Music]